et
bonjour je suis isabelle i/s à
bellsystem24 émission montre moi un
signe les entendants et les sous ont du
mal à communiquer je vais nous apprendre
des mots de la langue des signes pour
que la communication soit plus facile
aujourd'hui nous allons voir les
couleurs pour ça nous partons dans un
magasin de vêtements
bonjour madame bonjour je suis sourde
vous comprenez la langue des signes
non désolé mais je peux vous aider
cette robe bleue
je la voudrait en jaune vous n'aimez pas
celle d'accord celle là
c'est pas ça pas vers je voudrais du
jaune
désolé je ne comprends pas
elle n'a pas compris
il y à différents signes pour les
couleurs je veux du jaune c'est ça le
signe de jaune
je vais essayé de miner jaune c'est
comme le soleil a le soleil du soleil a
le soleil et jaune
elle a trouvé jaune
aux jeunes
les entendants et les sourds sont
différents les entendants écoute la
sonnerie alors que les sourds observe
par exemple un entendant entend la
sonnerie bonjour et pour un sourd
il est assis dans son fauteuil avec son
chien à côté et puis il voit son chien
aboyer à j'ai compris ça veut dire que
quelqu'un a sonné
les sourds peuvent faire comme les
entendants
mais différemment
les entendants écoute alors que des
sourds sont plutôt visuel bonjour mme
aux couleurs roi au maire
jaune bleu vert
rouge
ouah
laon
au revoir à bientôt
et